شخصيا بدات منذ نعومه اظافري وانا ارسم
بدات فعليا اكثر بالظهور عام 2012 كان اول
معرض شاركت فيه يعتبر حضور متاخر ذكيه
المتعب في فنها في اعمالها
لكل شيء وقت لكل شيء وقت في الحياه نقدر
نقول انه انت بداتي ثم توقفت في مرحله ثم
عدتي عدتي نعم نعم لو اخذنا هذه المراحل
كيف تشكلت وليش توقفتي
مراحل اول شيء يعني مثلا مرحله الطفوله
كنت ارسم فيها كثير كنت مميزه طبعا
في مدرستي اني من وانا صغيره بيسموني
فنانه المدرسه
الشرقيه
اول ما درست بالرياض
سنه اولى جامعه كان كنت في سكن الداخلي
للطالبات بعليجه كان ما شاء الله لدينا
مهتمين يعني فينا كثيرا كان في قسم
الانشطه فانا دخلت النشاط الفني وشاركت في
معرض
كانت هذه اول انطلاقه لي يعني شفت
فيها ردود الناس
تجاهها اعمالي
وبعدين توقفت
بعد يعني فهذه على طول بعد المعرض انجبت
بنتي الاولى والثانيه بعدها والثالثه صارت
مسؤوليه
كثيره وتوظفت والزواج والوظيفه
حددت من
طموحاتك الفنيه نقول ولا شلون ما كان في
حالات صراع بين انه يعني انا شغوفه بهذا
العالم بدي اكمل فيه ولكن هناك ما يعيقنا
يعني المسؤوليات الحياه الاسره وغيرها او
الزواج
اكون معك صريحه لا لا يعني ما كنت كثير قد
ما اكون كنت مركزه على عملي وعلى اسرتي ما
كان في وقت
توقفتيه وبعدين رجعت عام 2012 شاركت زي ما
قلت لحضرتك في اول معرض كان في جماعه
التشكيل بالقطيف شاركت فيه العام الثاني
عشر لديهم
وكان في هناك ورشه تقام
شهر رمضان المبارك يقوم فيها ويعدها بعض
من الفنانين من المنطقه الله يعطيهم
العافيه وبعد كده بعد الورشه يقام معرض
جماعي فهذا كان اول معرض تقريبا اقدر اقول
فيه لا جماعي معرض جماعي 2012 معرض الشخصي
لا بعد ذلك اول معرض شخصي كان
في
جون 2012 2018 كان في الخبر 2018
فتره طويله ليه لان الفنان لازم يكون جاهز
قبل اعداد معرض شخصي له لازم يكون جاهز
بادواتها بتقنياتها
[موسيقى]
يعني مش اي فنان مبتدا ويبدا معرض شخصي